we can talk about joe rogan okay being
insulted
on the simpsons did you see this al oh
we don't know if he was insulted keep
going like they attempted to insult him
i'm assuming but we don't know joe was
insulted
good point i thought it was funny who
knows good or like uh most people he
probably didn't know it happened because
who watches the simpsons i didn't know
they were making new simpson episodes
did not know either
i thought they predicted i didn't i
thought it was an old episode i think
it's from the 90s
yeah that is a thing that's a thing
where the simpsons predicts the future
what do they think will be they predict
how bad their show would get in the year
2000 is it bad now i honestly don't know
it's been rough for a long time really
yeah yeah i mean they had a great run
great run i mean i maybe i've rewatched
old episodes and maybe i'm just
nostalgic but i'm like yo this is
[ __ ] great yeah and then you i saw an
episode where they tried to do an
anti-trump thing and it was like they
broke into a song and it was like yo
this is embarrassing that you guys are
putting this out it was so bad so
unfunny so unentertaining didn't say
anything like simpsons used to say [ __ ]
that cut now it's just like even the
rogan thing is like what are you trying
to say i don't understand yeah what do
they say the roman thing i guess homer
gets cancelled in this episode and
nobody wants anything to do with him
mose shuts the door on him some other
place that he always goes to shuts the
door on him like literally see a montage
and then he goes to what's supposed to
be joe rogan studio it doesn't say joe
rogan it just says right wing podcast
studio or something and then one thing
underneath ryan
is welcome joe rogan opens the door
welcomes homer in and then homer slams
the door on joe rogan
yeah so homer won't even go there that's
how crazy that is yeah yeah nobody wants
to be a part of joe rogan's podcast that
11 million people listen to every day
yeah it's just like not funny who
wouldn't do rogan
every one of those simpsons writers
would do rogue in a second yes they
probably have i think azaria's been on
it yeah really we should look and see
but i think he has i think so so it's
like what are you talking about
i hate seeing this [ __ ] hank azaria just
cuffed out for this whole industry yeah
it's it's so weird like you even saw it
with the kimmel thing like kimmel had a
joke about like the knelt boys yeah this
is embarrassing too and and i wonder if
they're just completely detached
like i wonder if kimmel's just
completely detached from reality and
they live and exist in the hollywood
bubble and because i i felt like this
when i was on that movie set i was like
oh they don't know anything is going on
yeah outside of this world like movies
are what's important to them and
anything that's not movies doesn't
matter right and i'm walking around this
set and i'm just like
and obviously my my ego was bruised yeah
it was like i was like complete nothing
on the set even though i'm like
surrounded by people who are like i
think i'm more successful or further in
my career including jonah and eddie that
there was oh geez i mean julie lee
dreyfus like david duke david duke of me
now right like it's like and who is
awesome but like julie derive she's the
[ __ ] female greatest sitcom of all
time right she was a massive man
is spitting is a punchline funny to you
now is that a thing i laughed at that
earlier okay yeah true um
did you did you see what jim
let's see let's see what's going on
this is really something a small group
of youtubers known as the nelco boys now
these guys he's talking about trump show
up at mar-a-lago and sweatshirts and
shorts logos all over their clothes
trump sits down for an hour with them
during a war to answer the dopiest
questions one of the great things about
trump is doesn't matter who's
interviewing him he's gonna it could be
george stephanopoulos or three doofuses
who brought a 12-pack of hard seltzer
along with him he's going to answer the
same way
and then kyle from the notepost
posted and says this small group of
youtubers has way more viewers than you
buddy kimmel used to be which i love
canadians even when they're in social
media there's a buddy in there yeah more
viewers than you buddy kimmel used to be
way funnier but now he's just washed up
and irrelevant only reason you even get
any views is because disney owns your
show so youtube forces it on everyone's
homepages last night is where comedians
late night is where comedians go to die
pack it in and let the big dogs take
over pal
amen
big dog
he's right yeah he's 100 right yeah all
right guys we can take a break for a
second because today's video is
sponsored by surf shark surfshark is a
modern vpn design with a user in mind
their utilities are powered by robust
security mechanisms but designed to be
simple and intuitive to use enjoy all
the freedoms of an open internet safely
and anonymously with no device limits
okay strictly
no logs means that they do not keep your
data okay you can unlock the 15 largest
netflix country libraries including the
united states and japan
now if you're in the u.s you're like why
do i need that maybe you're on vacation
maybe you're on vacation you want to
keep watching drive to survive but you
can't because you're in another country
and akash what maybe other countries got
a lot more [ __ ] than we do on if you
want our fresh prince netflix in england
there you go by merely connecting to a
server in the right country you can
access all that also reach your favorite
sites and services even in countries
that ban them as surf shark bypasses
censorship and geo-blocking to give you
access to facebook and china or tick
tock in the u.s 30-day money-back
guarantee gives users plenty of time to
try out surf shark risk-free so you can
get 83 off a two-year plan and three
extra months for free go to
surfshark.dlslash
schultz and use the code schultz to get
83 off a two-year plan and three extra
months for free protect yourself online
today who's watching kimmel and you two
million people i mean on his on
linear on tv it's two million people
it's nothing yeah it's not that much
it's really not that much and i don't
know who's watching any of youtube of
kimmel's youtube stuff
yeah i don't think i mean
so much and paid ads to push that [ __ ]
up yeah
yeah
it gets views but then also the tv
viewing audience is old people here's my
questions making jokes that speak to old
people here's my question about that
clip these young kids with the labels
with the logos and you know yeah he's
insulting logos yeah
yeah where was the actual punch line in
that clip that's what bothered me is you
used to be funny even if i don't agree
with what you're saying give me punch
lines give me jokes three doofuses
sitting in a room they just bought a 12
pack of hard sell sir these aren't punch
lines
it's not funny
i can't defend this and i liked camel
for a long time but now it's getting
like yo this is embarrassing but what if
you're the old person who looks at young
kids like that now you're speaking to me
yeah we forget that he's like 60 or
something how old is jimmy kimmel
gotta be 50 something at least 50 and
change but the audience is much older um
you know what it might be
i love how he was like trump is talking
these guys in the middle of a war
like he's supposed to do something like
he's in office still he's just a guy now
yeah yeah like how dare obama get
coveted in the middle of a war yeah once
president you're always president like
what would you like him to do yeah what
should he do should he go to the ukraine
yeah or he wouldn't want that yeah he
actually might
well yeah it's just such a weird thing
you know what yeah al's point you know
what might have happened is we grew up
with this guy when he was hip and in
touch and so we see him as that and
young people just look at him the way we
looked at like 80 year olds on tv yeah
but to us he's a guy we grew up with so
now that he's out of touch we don't
realize he just fell out of touch yeah
also think about it like i guess to make
an argument for like him and his
constituents like think about how we are
when we find a new youtuber that has 20
million subscribers but we didn't even
know who the [ __ ] they were yeah we're
just like where's this guy been yeah you
know like there are people who just
haven't found out about beast yeah and
they're like wait what are you
100 million yeah where where the [ __ ]
have i been i mean even rogan during the
parties like you bought an island
couldn't believe it there's no hate
behind it so it's no hate it's truly not
knowing so he maybe is seeing this video
of these young kids also like this is
being hand fed to him right like the
writers are handing the sam and he
watches the video that they're handing
him and he's like oh yeah it makes sense
so low-key like it's on him to research
the things he's talking about or trust
the people
that he's hiring to make sure he doesn't
look foolish like if i'm him i'm
going after the person that wrote that
like the the quality control of his
writers and i'm basically going yo don't
make me look like out of touch and
stupid ever again yeah like they have an
interview show where they interview
famous people all the time kids too
you're talking to selena gomez yeah stop
acting like you don't speak to this
younger demo yeah if you only spoke to
older people i'd be okay that's one
thing you were actively trying to appeal
to the youth yeah especially if if it's
a tv show that that's where the old
people are watching it he knows that the
only way to survive long term is that
the youtube numbers need to explode to
get new numbers so he knows the youtube
world like don't say that he doesn't
like yeah if he's smart though i think
he has him on the show
like kim will like invite an outboys on
ugh no but that would be um he might do
it i mean it would be amazing abc got to
be okay with it disney gotta be
[ __ ] do
it technically they can i mean oh really
well no i mean they're super connected
to ufc that's part of espn you know they
have an espn plus thing that's abc like
i feel like at this level like people
who have nbc shows go on abc to promote
their own show of course
that would be old-school kimmel doing
something good and interesting that'd be
great what it feels like now this felt
like the bill cosby moment where he was
like telling black kids to pull up their
pants and we're all like yo
you lost it you you are out of you
you're out of touch you're gone that's
what this feels like and in general we
talked about this earlier it feels like
kimmel doesn't have teeth anymore yeah
like you used to have teeth whether you
agreed or not you were like there was an
edge to what you're saying now you're
looking at it and like this is nothing
yeah this is like nothing there's no
punch line anywhere yeah you're
chuckling oh no i'm just
thinking about other comedians that
don't have teeth oh yeah
yeah what happened to the old kimmel you
know the kim will do blackface he
changed so much like back in the day
used to have real teeth yeah i love that
guy yeah he was great he was he was
funny when he was black
as a black dude
100 yeah the t thing is so true it's
like if comedy doesn't have teeth it's
it's hard for me to watch it yeah i feel
like i'm just wasting my time the man
show
agree or disagree with her that she had
teeth you were going to feel away about
it earlier kimmel earlier kimmel dude
and you didn't like it but remember when
he went on leno and lena was taking his
show back from conan and he just starts
grilling leno about why are you taking
conan show back on leno oh yeah that was
funny that [ __ ] you could like it or not
but they had teeth man that was ballsy
yeah there's no balls here this is
castrated yeah and it's rough to watch
yeah as somebody who grew up being like
yo this guy's a funny one yeah yeah late
night wars feel like like england versus
scotland you know what i mean like it
used to be a real war that people cared
about but now it's kind of like all
right who gives a [ __ ]
he's like you guys have your own little
beef like any time late night guys try
to kick up stuff it's like all right
yeah it's like cricket or something
stupid
you didn't need to take a shot at me
like cricket a lot like that but then
you make fun of me and it goes for a
circle yeah it's like cricket
or some french canadian thing that
nobody was the [ __ ] about that yeah what
up people you just watched a clip from
our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace